tres años de un acontecimiento que
parecía abocar a una nueva guerra en
medio oriente el 3 de enero de 2020 un
bombardeo con un dron estadounidense
mató a casensolimani el líder de las
fuerzas militares de élite iranís alcut
junto a book macri al muhandi su jefe de
las fuerzas de movilización Popular de
Irak el lunes miles de iraquíes
desfilaron durante una ceremonia
conmemorativa cerca del aeropuerto de
Bagdad
en este día este lugar se convirtió en
un símbolo porque fue testigo de un gran
crimen mediante el cual se violó la
soberanía y la unidad de iraq
no hay justificación para atacar a estos
dos líderes que lucharon contra las
fuerzas del extremismo y la oscuridad
esta protesta pide la
internacionalización de este asunto y
que se responsabilice a los criminales
que atentaron contra estos altos
dirigentes
solimani era considerado uno de los
hombres con más poder en la región Terán
prometió vengar la muerte del líder que
desencadenó una ola de protestas en la
pública islámica Irak y Siria
incrementando las tensiones regionales
mientras el entonces presidente de
Estados Unidos Donald Trump se
justificaba en un ataque contra el
terrorismo
el mensaje que podríamos transmitir hoy
es de rechazo a todo lo que tiene lugar
y Presenta una violación descarnada de
la soberanía de Irak y subrayar que el
enfoque estadounidense se basa en el
terror
tres años después Irán pasa de La
amenaza de conflicto a escala
internacional al desafío interno por las
masivas protestas antigubernamentales
que iniciaron en septiembre con la
muerte de la joven maxa mini en custodia
policial